this is cereth registered nurse re and
calm and in this video I want to be
going over to in click style questions
that will test your knowledge on health
assessment and don't forget to check out
the other questions in this series so
let's get started
our first question says you're
performing a head-to-toe assessment on a
patient admitted with abdominal pain
during inspection of the abdomen
you know the abdominal contour to be
round and distended with no masses or
lesions present the patient reports that
their last bowel movement was one hour
ago in the stool was loose in addition
the patient states that the abdominal
pain is located below the umbilicus and
is sharp in quality after inspection of
the abdomen you will a perform light
palpation on the abdomen followed by
deep palpation be percuss the abdomen
see auscultate for bowel sounds by
starting in the right lower quadrant or
D palpate for brewery's and rebound
tenderness so in this scenario we are
performing our head-to-toe assessment on
a patient who is admitted with abdominal
pain so we really want to focus on that
abdomen and according to the scenario
we've already inspected the abdomen we
found that the abdominal contour is
rounded their stomach is distended but
there's no masses or lesions and the
patient told us their last bowel
movement and they are having abdominal
pain so what are we gonna do next since
we've already inspected well what you
want to be doing is you want to be
pulling from that health assessment
knowledge and remembering that
particular order of how we execute our
head-to-toe assessment normally first we
inspect then we palpate percuss and then
lastly we auscultate now with the
abdomen it's different with every other
system you're gonna do that except with
the abdomen with abdomen we're gonna
change it up a little bit first what
we're gonna do is we're gonna inspect
which is what you do first up there then
second we're going to auscultate then
thirdly we're gonna percuss and then
palpate so why
we doing this second instead of last
okay the whole reason we change it up is
because we want to prevent all train
those vowel sounds
because think about it whenever you go
and you do light palpation and deep
palpation on the abdomen you're
manipulating and messing with those
intestines squishing that stuff around
so that can produce a bowel sounds so
initially we just want to look at that
stomach and then we want to listen with
our set the gut stethoscope
to those sounds see if we hear anything
so that's the whole reasoning for it so
whatever you're looking at those options
you are looking for an option that is
talking about performing auscultation
listening with your stethoscope and
after reading all of our options the
only one that talks about listening with
a stethoscope is C so we're answer is C
we're going to auscultate for bowel
sounds by starting in that right lower
quadrant then after that we would listen
for those vascular sounds on the abdomen
of the aorta the renal artery the iliac
artery all those and we're listening for
brewery's then we would perk us and then
lastly we would palpate so that's why a
is wrong that's why B is wrong it's
talking about percussion and then D is
wrong for a couple reasons
he says pal VapoRub Ruiz no we don't
have a four breweries we listen for
breweries that swishing noise that
shouldn't be there so that's why that's
wrong and of course it's talking about
palpating for rebound children
tenderness and we would do that last so
our answer is C now let's look at our
next question you're performing a
head-to-toe assessment on a patient
while palpating the lymph nodes of the
neck the patient reports tenderness at
the following location when you document
the findings of the head-to-toe
assessment you will note that the
patient felt tenderness at which lint
node site a preauricular B submandibular
C superficial cervical or D jugular
digastric so to answer this question you
have
to know where all those lip node sites
are in the neck and what they are called
so let's review those so if you start
from the top and work your way down you
will first you will find in front of the
ears
the preauricular then behind the ear the
post our Rick Euler and a little bit
down from that at the base of the head
the abscissa tool then a little bit down
from the ear in the neck you will find
the jugular digastric then down from
there you'll have the sub mandibular and
this is where below the mandible and
then a little bit under the chin you can
find the submental and up a little bit
next to where the jugular digastric is
you will find the parotid lymph node and
as you work your way down the neck you
will find the superficial cervical and
then the ones down in the yellow is the
deep cervical chain and these go down
through the anterior and posterior sides
of the sterno mastoid muscle so you will
find those in those different areas and
then a little bit posterior to that is
the posterior cervical and right above
where the clavicle is you will find the
supra clavicular so the answer to this
question would be jugular digastric that
is where we would document that the
patient felt the pain okay so that wraps
up this review of those two health
assessment questions and don't forget to
check out the other questions in this
series thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos